what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts morning coffee
thoughts where I
give my opinions um out out dating and
relationships and
sorry okay we're arguing my opinions on
dating and relationships and I don't
know just like life you know things that
I think about in society so
today I want to talk to you guys about
submission
for the two women that watch me okay
the two ladies you know
I want to talk about a submission in a
way that maybe women can understand it a
little bit better okay
men want submissive women
however women feel like
we are scared to submit
now why is women are we afraid to submit
women throughout all of history have not
been afraid to submit
they just did it well
there's a couple reasons okay one the
government subsidizes our bad decisions
so we're able to be alone
and we're able to not have to figure out
a man to submit to because you know if a
man's not going to take care of us the
government sure as hell well
or you've built a society where maybe we
can get like a market a cushy marketing
job
so it's not really necessary so a lot of
to survive in society I'm not saying
it'll make I'm not saying we'll be happy
in the long term but it's not
necessarily like you need to submit to
survive okay so as women we really don't
have a lot of practice
when have we really practiced submitting
in all honesty
were you taught to submit to your
brothers in your household were you was
your parents marriage one where your
mother submitted to your father Maybe
not maybe your mom ran the show
and that's okay
that's okay we cannot help where we
start but what we can do is listen to
the men and take notes okay so this is
what I've grown to understand about
submission submission
think about a boss okay
now
you pick a boss to like you pick the job
you want to work at similarly we pick
the husbands we want right I'm not
saying they'll pick you back you know
you might have chose LeBron James and
he's like I got like three side pieces
waiting for me Diane you know but but
so finally finally you apply for a
couple jobs one takes you and you're on
board now if a guy has hired you
does he want an employee that's
questioning his every decision
the CEO of let's say let's say you're
running a Starbucks okay do you want a
barista where you say hey make that
order are you sure it was that ordered
are you sure that's what the customer
said you might be right
this is the thing you might be right
the customer may have said a different
drink but if you don't listen to what he
says the whole structure of the
organization will crumble because your
employees the employees under you
are then also going to question his
judgment and his decision making
similarly if you're constantly
questioning your husband's decision
making calling him an idiot saying men
are dumb your father you know who also
is going to question his decision making
the children and here's the thing guys
kids talk okay
if you're a neurotic woman
who's always bagging on her husband
at some point the kids will grow up and
see it they're gonna see
who was right and who is wrong let's
just say that
and at some point if you do not respect
the father of your children and your
husband
your kids will resent you for it they
will grow up one day they will see how
you treated a good man
and it will teach your daughters not to
respect the men there with and it will
teach your sons
that they don't deserve women that
respect them they won't know how how is
a a son supposed to know that he should
look for a submissive wife is he if he's
never seen one if he doesn't even know
what that looks like so you might think
that oh well
I'm doing the right thing by bitching to
my husband because I'm figuring out the
Starbucks order and that's really what
the customer said and I was right well
do you want to be right
or do you want to be right and have a
bunch of problems later or do you want
to be
do you want to maybe
be wrong or I don't want to say be wrong
make the wrong decision but the
structure of the company's intact now
look look I'm not saying to date idiots
okay again as women We're Not Gonna date
we're not going to be involved with men
that have nothing going for them now it
might just be a looks thing okay
and if you want to have a dynamic where
you're just dating a dumb idiot and
that's the type of menu day okay lead
the relationship have fun have a great
time okay but I'm assuming that you're
you're a half smart woman okay and if
he's not the type of guy you could if
he's not the type of boss you could work
for
that you would have been out the door
before you had a kid
I'm assuming and and if you weren't
you got some self-reflection to do love
because you make some idiotic decisions
idiotic I don't know how y'all
get pregnant okay I really don't
like
even if you don't want to be on birth
control okay maybe that's your argument
I don't want to be on birth control it's
going to hurt my butt okay
fine honey fine honey
track your cycle that's one okay
abstinence that's another or maybe
only sleep with men that you could see
being good Fathers
that you trust enough you know if it
goes that way look at who who am I
though you know Pearl just a girl with
some opinions all right that you can
take or you can leave
now
why would you respect a boss's decision
even if you think it's wrong
because you know he built up this
company that you want to work for
and that at the end of the day maybe
sometimes you don't like the decisions
maybe sometimes you think he's an idiot
but overall you trust his leadership and
you're going to follow him now are there
times where you gotta you gotta quit and
jump ship this is a question
well
sure yeah I mean yes yes I mean I would
recommend doing that before you have
kids
but other times where life changes
where
maybe things happen and you know
um
your boss is going crazy all right like
that happens sometimes you know like for
example the death of a child the death
of a child I'm pretty I don't know what
the divorce rate is in that
last I checked it was pretty freak I
could Google it but like it doesn't
matter
that could drive someone mad
and so personally I'm I'm through I'm on
the team stick it out through thick and
thin but
you know if they're going mental are
there times where you got to change
employers sure yes
but can you blame the next employer for
questioning hiring you if you're
constantly jumping from employer to
employer to employer to employer and you
have no loyalty
or you've applied for you know what are
these what are they body counts they're
saying 37 jobs and got none of them it's
like
the next employer is going to be like
what why were you not hired at any of
those why didn't you keep any of those
jobs
so you get fired from all of them you
left all of them anyways my point is
this
um
that's submission guys submission is not
my husband's gonna be right all the time
also let's let's good bosses take their
employees opinions into considerations
okay I'll give you an example my
producer blessing is a genius he is
genuinely a genius you speak see how
highly I speak of this man literally a
genius
and
when we were putting together the studio
this man spent so much on my credit card
I almost killed him I swear to God I
almost killed him
he spent an entire month's ad Revenue on
this goddamn Studio but you know what I
did
I just trusted him because I was like
you know what he knows more about this
stuff than I do
and he built me in my opinion the best
studio in all in the whole Space
um
I really can't think of anyone that's
got a better Studio than us
um it cost Goddamn money
but but but I was like you know what I
trust him and that's how it works with a
good boss employee relationship your
boss a good boss is gonna want you to do
what you're good at is going to want you
to recognize your strengths
and at times are they going to override
some of your decisions because they are
looking at the direction of the company
sure yes they absolutely are however
however
a good boss is going to delegate a lot
of decisions to you
um I had a couple girls in my show they
make a lot of women make all the
financial decisions in the household the
guy makes the money
but when it comes to spending the women
budgeted the women spend the money now
I'm not saying do that in your household
but a lot of guys don't even want to do
it so he has to make the money you just
get to spend it
but he might for the bigger financial
decision say you know what don't want a
house in that area want a house over
there
like what what if a man wanted to move
you into a house that you really in Your
Heart of heart soul of Soul did not like
and let's say you put 50 of the money
into it
because most of y'all are average chicks
right
most of us aren't going to be getting
these super high earning men so we can't
expect them to pay all the bills right
most of us are average gals so
it's likely you might be in a 50 50 type
deal right so
if that's the case if you put 50 of the
money into it
would you still respect his decision
and for a lot of you the answer is no
and if you think
that a household where you're constantly
arguing over the big decisions and every
time you disagree it's a screaming match
and you have to talk and talk and talk
and talk until the guy gives in and just
says fine have a your way honey if
that's the type of marriage you want I
mean
go for it that's that's your prerogative
but I just wouldn't recommend it
those men seem Miserable Now the next
question would your husband really
co-sign that you submit go ask him if he
got a husband boyfriend
and asking for his honest feedback men
will tell you but you can't get mad at
his his feedback if he says no
it might be something you got to work on
guys
it's all about really identifying where
you're at and trying to improve this is
not to say modern women are doomed
although a lot of a lot of modern women
are
but it's not because they have to be
doomed it's because their expectations
don't meet reality
you know if they had more realistic
expectations they might have better
outcomes
so
yeah
um that's submission though guys so
it's not easy okay like if you're if
your guy told hey I need you to like if
your guy said shut the [__] up and bring
me my coffee are you gonna do it are you
gonna argue with him I don't like your
tone
and a lot of times the funny thing with
men is when men are like rude to women
or like whatever
a lot of times they feel a little bad
like they're stressed out they feel a
little bad you come back later
and they kind of feel bad so they're
nice to you later if you're just a
little bit patient with them if you
don't give them so much pushback like
now am I saying
you need to date you need to pick a boss
that speaks to you in that way no you
are welcome to quit at any time but my
my point is why don't you quit before
you have a kid
now are there exceptions to the rules
sure but at the end of the day
traditional women real traditional women
if you Google it the family before me
traditional Women Believe
that family and Legacy is more important
than their own personal happiness if you
don't believe this then you are not a
traditional woman you believe you have a
modern mindset because you believe that
your happiness is above the families so
if you're not happy in a marriage
and and you leave that that's a modern
mindset traditional women
they're at the end they're like ride or
die it's thick and thin anyways
um
anyways that's that's my coffee talk on
submission I've learned a lot about it
in the past year or two it's okay if you
don't know what it is it's okay if
you're not a submissive woman
you can't help where you start
but once you have this information
you can work on it
honestly like learning red pill stuff
has helped me
have so like even just
take take the dating out of it you
nosies your nosies but even with my my
dad and my brothers it's like
my my little brother I speak about my
little I really am a fan of my little
brother I'm a fan of my big brother too
but but I talk about Adam he's the one I
talk to the most he really
he he's a he's a bit stubborn he's kind
of a
he's kind of an [__] sorry Adam if
you're watching this sorry he is he
really is he's a dick like he can be
rude he can be coarse he can be whatever
but and my other sister because I have a
lot of I'm not gonna say names but she
has an issue with Adam like they they
like be a butt heads sometimes and I
tell her
I say so and so
you know if you just listen to what Adam
says he's right about a lot of stuff
and honestly he's bossy but if you just
because I think they butt head they're
both kind of bossy they kind of but I'm
like if you just listened honestly he's
gonna help you more than anyone my
little brother if I need help with
anything he'll help me literally
anything I remember when he was like 10.
there's a time where my car was so
freaking messy my room was so messy and
I was just like I'm so overwhelmed
because I had volleyball and all this
stuff he spent
the entire day
helping me at like 10. what did he get
out of that nothing
um because I'm like four or maybe he was
12 I don't know I was like 16 I think so
however
what is he three years younger whatever
he was a kid and
a lot of siblings want to do that it's
like well why do I have to help you you
know and it's because
men want to help women who respect them
you certainly and I'm not even talking
about money because in all honesty
money in my opinion and maybe this is
because I'm a spoiled like I'm you guys
say I'm out of touch
fine maybe I am all right but
I think money is like the least thing
that a guy can give you like if I had to
think of all the things that I I've
gotten from men in my life okay
and I I really in terms of gifts and
stuff like
some nice stuff but it has you know I'm
not saying I've gotten a ton but like
even if I did even if I got all this
money or whatever
I
I think that the greatest things and
like resources that I have maybe gotten
from men is wisdom in all honesty like
wisdom Direction
um
like my the best thing that my dad has
ever given me has not been you know
paying for my college it's not been
anything like they got me a car when I
was six I mean don't don't get me wrong
I enjoyed those you know what I mean
like let's not I'm not gonna cap but the
greatest things that my dad has done for
me in my life is literally the ability
to call him and ask him about a problem
and get his take because men just think
in a different way that women do and
they're much more logical I'll give you
an example
there was broadly about this because I
don't
there was some
people
um that I had I had to let go okay
and this is hard this is really hard for
me because I've built relationships with
people you know it's just not but when
it came down to it I'm showing my dad
the work they've been doing and I'm
showing him how much I pay
and he my dad you know men are more
disagreeable so they're they're more
likely to say oh that's not a fair deal
where
women might say
well but they've had a hard time not
that I was doing well but so-and-so's
trying and this and this and this and
men really just look at the numbers they
look at the work and they say fair or
unfair and honestly I was having so much
stress because these particular people
were not doing doing their job and it
was just getting to be so stressful for
me like you could see over break like
the number oh my gosh the coffee talks I
did I just looked freaking stressed out
and as soon as I got rid of them and
replaced them and had some people that
were actually working you know
oh my gosh
I was so much less stressed out
okay like I felt like
it was like oh my gosh I just I had more
free time anyways but
if it was up to me I probably would have
just kept doing what we were doing
trying to figure out
I probably just would have added an ad I
don't know I don't know what I would
have did but
it's like you know how women
break up with men
and they've been thinking about this
breakup for months it's kind of the same
thing with employees
where men are much more quick with it
we're women we just have to weigh out
the pros and cons but oh duh no that's
not good in business and thank you God I
have my my dad for that my dad was also
the one that told me to follow what I
what I'm passionate about in life
because he and that was just good advice
because he he would say do what you love
and you're going to be better at it than
everyone because you're going to put in
more hours that's why people will say I
work a lot and maybe I do but it's
honestly so fun for me that I forget I'm
working
I love this I mean
not always the last couple months I've
been really stressed out so
but a lot of that stress was coming from
doing people's job that weren't for
anyways I'm not gonna get into that but
this is my point
the most
useful things you can get from men has
nothing to do with money and a lot of
you [__] are so focused on the money
you're so focused on getting money and
resources you don't even realize that is
the least valuable thing you can get
from a man
except maybe Jeff bezos's wife
I'm not
y'all probably that's probably more
valuable than anything my dad could do
in terms of advice
um but even even so I wouldn't trade it
I wouldn't trade it because
the insight and the mental stability
that comes from just like
seeing things in a more logical way
brings me peace in my life and that's
what I want I don't care about money I
want peace anyways let me know what you
guys think in the comments subscribe to
the channel ring that notification Bell
I'll talk to you next time